bonjour brut je m'appelle andré
brugiroux j'ai 83 ans et mon histoire
c'est celle d'un jeune qui est parti à
17 ans et 10 francs en poche pour les
causses et qui a réussi après a visité
tous les pays du monde et tous les
territoires sans exception en fait j'ai
rien fait d'autre dans ma vie j'ai pris
une vie sabbatique au cours de sa vie
andré a visité de 151 pays et
territoires parcouru 400 mille
kilomètres autour du monde en stop et
tout ça avec un dollar par jour pour
brut
il raconte ça c'est une photo par
exemple pas si on le voit ces prêts au
spitzberg en fait le spitzberg c'est une
île du cheval bart et les gens m'avaient
dit sur le bateau qui allait cinq ans
lorsqu'il ya plein d'oiseaux qui vont
attaquer parce que les gens ils ont pour
habitude ce qui bouge pas de décourager
celui qui veut bouger
tu vas les lattes pas revenir vivante si
j'avais écouté les changera jamais bougé
d'ailleurs quand je suis entré au bout
de 18 ans premier voyage la voisine et
m'a dit comment vous a été voir tous ces
ouvrages
je fais le tour de l'iran short un
patchwork de moi alors les iranienne
regarde et me disait vous mini joue mon
short mini joue pas alors on a une chose
qu'on ne trouve pas dans les boutiques
de france qu'elle appelle des étuis
appendices en papouasie les hommes et
son poil est le matin quand le gars il
se lève voilà la seule chose qu'ils
n'ont fils s'était tu es tu un pénis la
motivation de dépasser curiosité
d'esprit insatiable j'ai voyagé pour
apprendre pour comprendre pas pour vous
pour passer le temps pour un promu
j'étais une parachutée dans ces pays-là
shell panneaux de la langue et je n'ai
pas de boulot j'y allais comme ça après
en espagne j'ai débarqué au temps de
franco
je tremblais mesurer les genoux qui
jouait les castagnettes avec trois ans
d'économies j'ai tenu les 6 ans sans
travailler et c'est là que j'ai parcouru
les 400 mille kilomètres un stock
je dépensais ses économies au compte
gouttes le dollar par jour alors ça
c'était tout allait dans la nourriture
et les visas mais le dollar s'explique
parce que j'ai jamais dormi à l'hôtel je
mangeais pas dans les restaurants et je
faisais que du stop et j'en suis le
premier
à mon âge canonique ce que je me bouge
un peu cela je me rends compte que j'ai
plus de jus dans les jambes j'ai pu la
force de marcher vite comme avant le
double maintenant ça c'est lorsqu'il ya
des pays j'allais à la prison principale
langue l'anglais la petite souris et les
gars je fais le tour du bon set up la
jeune diva est ce que je peux dormir
dans votre présence est pas une cellule
de libre ryanair et des bas mais on a
une chute à 40 dans quel pays bas il
faut aux états unis ça m'arrivait de
fait vous aviez d'aidé vraiment des gros
moments de peur ou pas pendant tout le
voyage
ah bin là les trous et oui moi je suis
pas très grave quand on a 5 me croyais
est dans l'écho de croyez qu'on a pas
peur venezuela ils m'ont pris pour un
castriste en afghanistan va je me suis
retrouvé là avec une baïonnette entre
les deux yeux sur le cominois un
militaire qui braillaient comme un âne
avec sa bouille mitraille je croyais
qu'elle aime faire un troisième oeil le
voyage dépend du voyageur et la beauté
dans les yeux
je mets ce saint-exupéry disait on ne
comprend pas bien qu'avec le coeur
ces salles sont récompensions la
compréhension intellectuelle qui est
importante mais la vraie compréhension
c'est celle du coeur la terre n'est
qu'un seul pays et tous les hommes sont
les citoyens
voilà la conclusion tous ces années de
route